foreign
Manufacturing in a country like
Argentina is a constant struggle says
who has been working in this family
business for 30 years
Argentina is battling with inflation
that has reached 120 percent in the past
year a shortage of foreign reserves and
a more than 40 billion dollar debt with
international monetary fund
Manfred says his strategy is to
constantly adapt
it is an art because every day there is
something new a new tax or a new policy
you spend all your time thinking on how
to make it work
the government recently announced a new
agreement with the IMF after it was
unable to comply with last year's debt
restructuring
factories like this one produce in
Argentina but also have some imports
from China like this rivet that you can
see right here the government has now
announced a new tax on Imports that in
effect will devaluate the peso as part
of an agreement with the international
monetary fund
the IMF wants Argentina to devalue the
local currency to help stop the outflow
of US dollars but the government fears
that evaluation will translate into more
inflation that's one of the reasons why
there are 14 different exchange rates
each for a different sector of the
economy
says the country needs predictability
and not constantly changing rules
you need a fertile terrain stability
which will allow us to generate jobs and
grow the economy
elections this year have caused more
uncertainty president Alberto Fernandez
won't be running again
Argentina's failed to comply with IMF
reforms on accumulation of debt and
reducing fiscal deficit the impact of
droughts has made everything worse and
the IMF knows it and that's why it's
accepting the new agreement but it's
becoming more strict and we'll likely
see this in the new year
for argentinians the economic crisis has
become endemic and many have managed to
thrive in spite of it
others are becoming increasingly
disheartened what is certain however is
that whoever wins the presidency in
October will face an uphill battle
Reviving the economy
it is